bertha's family is trying desperately to
break in she's very socially ambitious
and what that means is that she has to
sort of break the code
this sort of stunt does not impress the
people you want to win over mrs morris
this sort of stunt impresses everyone
she is new money she's part of this new
wave of industrialists so her husband
has gotten his hand into the railroad
industry and they've made a fortune very
rapidly but of course the old money
families are trying to protect their
position as the american aristocracy i
don't know which is worse the noise of
the builders or the chance of running
into her in the street
bertha has a neighbor across the street
agnes van rein and her sister living in
a brownstone they're part of the old
money family they're sort of more
socially conservative they're not flashy
with their wealth and bertha russell has
moved in and built this palatial
residence right across the street from
them and they won't look her in the eye
and so part of the arc of the season for
her is trying to figure out how to
position herself so that agnes van rein
has to acknowledge that she exists she
becomes a real foil for bertha she
represents everything bertha isn't
i was also really drawn to playing
bertha because i found the marriage
between george and bertha russell really
compelling it struck me as shockingly
egalitarian for the time that this is
set i love that they're really in this
together there are moments my dear
when you are quite one of us useless
each without the other you get the sense
that they're very compatible and they're
hungry for the next step i just found
that really thrilling what i'm planning
might take a great many dollars my dear
we've made one fortune together and if
needs be we'll make him spend another
i also think it's a really interesting
time to consider how we feel about the
way these billionaires are living and
the way that that wealth is flaunted in
spite of tremendous hardship and of
course in addition to that all the
dynamics of love and family and marriage
and people wanting to fit in and wanting
to know
what their place is we're finally
getting to where we belong
[Music]
george is a fist in a velvet glove right
he is a late 19th century industrialist
a robber baron what would you do if he
won't play ball
build another line
right alongside his he is based a little
bit on jay gould gould was really
vilified in the papers at the time he
was someone who became a kind of living
embodiment of all of the inequality of
the era russell has more money than god
he has such insane levels of power and
sometimes he uses them on really
vulnerable people and just crushes them
like ants you bastard i may be a bastard
mr thorburn
but you are a fool george at home kind
of gets his ass kicked i'm a favorite to
ask you mean you want something and you
haven't asked your mother he is most
fundamentally a family man i mean a
person who's really driven by his love
for his children there's a sense of
george holding his power and reserves i
said i had no objection she had to get
your permission i will decide who comes
to dinner in this house george's
relationship with bertha is for me at
the heart of the show i'd just like you
to be happy
and i know my loving you is not enough
it's almost enough she has that kind of
desire for power but because of the era
in which she lived the way that that
gets to express itself is in this quest
for social status
and i think george sort of understands
this is what she has and so he
facilitates it and fights for it on her
behalf because she cares about it and so
he goes about you and mrs morris have
snubbed and belittled my wife how could
i allow that to go unpunished there's
something very romantic about that it's
just fascinating there's an aspect of
george where he gives his own fury free
reigns sometimes i'm afraid you must
face the music it's why the sort of
duality of being this very warm family
man but in business
being
just utterly almost inhuman is
fascinating
larry was just such a kind and excitable
young man i really related to his drive
to try and figure out where he sits in
everything and what sort of man he's
going to be
larry is
the
young happy-go-lucky son of george and
bertha russell he's a recent harvard
grad and he comes back from school to
try and figure out where his place is in
society and in the world and in his
family
larry's relationship with his parents is
pretty cheeky and fun he loves both of
them very much he really adores his
mother and he'll wind her up and make
fun of the things that she holds very
dear well obviously my mother couldn't
live in a house without a ballroom
you may laugh but as my mother never
tires of pointing out our future success
in new york depends entirely on the
support and approval of mrs astor
harry's relationship with gladys is
really sweet they really are best
friends and he looks after her and
really sticks up for her when she needs
someone in her corner to fight against
her controlling mum she's not a child
anymore you shouldn't treat her as one
she's a child until i say
he's a little bit of a disrupter within
his family he's obviously got all of
these societal expectations of who he's
meant to be and what job he's meant to
undertake and who he's meant to be
partnered with and he has a little bit
of cheek and starts to reject and
question some of the things that are
expected of him i should get going i'm
catching the 11 o'clock train to rhode
island but you've only just got home
is that what is this
[Music]
gladys has a bit of a rebellious nature
just a hint of it she doesn't always
want to conform to the rules of high
society
is the daughter of the richest numani
family the russells she like any
teenager on the brink of adulthood is
craving her own independence and the
chance to experience the world
i trust you'll take our part i certainly
intend to my daughter isn't out yet
she's only here to accompany me
but she's stuck she's stuck with a
mother who has so much control over her
she's stuck in a society where young
women are not allowed to have their own
identities or enjoy a sense of freedom
without a husband how strange these
rules are
why shouldn't you go out to dinner with
your brother and a friend what could be
more normal not to my mother there's a
mutual respect between gladys and her
brother larry they both
bond over their struggle with the unfair
expectations of their parents and i
suppose mothers made another quarrel i'm
afraid i can't stay either
i just wanted to look in to pay my
respects to your parents i hope we can
meet again i'm sure we will for gladys
she enjoys the fancy dresses and the
french chef and the butlers and the maid
and all that but she feels like she
could give all of that up just to be
happy she doesn't have that same desire
or desperation to be accepted into high
society the way that her mother birthed
us i gather we're going to christen the
new house just a few people calling in
but i think it's time how many are
coming it's hard to say as they don't
accept in a formal way but i think if we
cater for 200 it's probably safe
wow in this world of fancy dinners and
ball gowns and etiquette classes gladys
can sometimes feel like more of a doll
than a human and he feels like she's
suffocating sometimes and it's all for
the sake of a future that's not even
hers mother may i present mr van ride
how do you know my daughter sir well i
don't not really but i want to very much
we cannot always have what we want
church is the kind of person when he
sees something that's not happening
right he goes to it he doesn't walk past
it
church relates differently to mr and mrs
russell each he's mrs russell at home
she's in the drawing rooms or with mrs
morris is she indeed
well i won't disturb them i love my
relationship with mr russell we don't
have much to say to each other but when
he has something to say to me i know
it's going to be of substance
and i know he values my advice
it's thought of as a male dominated
culture which it was
but that was in one area
in the realm of the home and the
household women called the shots the
household is an enterprise which can be
more successful and less successful and
the church has a big investment in the
success of that enterprise as mrs
russell does and is everything ready for
mr larry's return i believe so madam but
i will check with mrs bruce thank you
church
mrs russell wants very passionately to
establish a beachhead in new york
society i want to help her do that
he is the butler it's his job to do this
but he would do it anyway in this kind
of household there are three principal
heads of the staff there's the butler
the cook and the housekeeper the butler
has overall responsibility for the
management of the household we live
together so it's not like a normal
business relationship we have to get
along this house is a folly with one
exception in this staff i have a great
relationship with him well miss turner i
hope you can overcome your distaste and
give the mistress a helping hand with
her clothes for the evening turner the
ladies made we have kind of a hostile
relationship
i like church he has a lot of pride
professional pride and i admire that a
lot
[Music]
you